are more males born after wars
do attractive parents have more girls if
either what's the mechanism
does anybody know um
so these are those are actually two very
different questions although they're
both related to
well the first one is specifically
related to the question of sex ratios
yep
and uh the second one is
a little bit the one about attracting
parents having more girls is a little
bit
uh related to sex ratios but more
um more to the question of sexual
selection and
how as parents can you maximize um
your genes going forward [ __ ] you know
as we've said over and over and over
again it's an uninteresting goal and in
humans
um this is sort of the least of what
parents do but it obviously still is
part of what parents do
is uh leaving copies of themselves the
next generation
hear that zach all right yeah he's on it
um so are more males born after wars
so you can do a number of things here
first of all just to make it clear
why you would expect it is that wars
tend to eliminate
men they don't just eliminate men right
wartime is bad for all sorts of things
for
all sorts of reasons but because men
fight wars and i believe that is a
cultural universal
yes um that men do the actual fighting
they are killed
at greater rates which would leave you
to expect that the production of men
um well there's two ways to think about
it you could think about it at a lineage
level
where there is a need for men and you
could think of it at the
individual level that is to say that
from the point of view of a parent
physiologically choosing whether to
produce a male or a female
females are liable to be in surplus
males are liable to be
uh scarce and therefore a male that you
had after war
might be disproportionately successful
both of which can be understood from a
sex racial perspective
which is to say um it's fisher right who
does sex ratio stuff
um so r.a fisher the father of minor
statistics and one of the best
evolutionary biologists of the 20th
century one of his contributions
was understanding that um
not even all else being equal but in
almost every circumstance in almost
every circumstance there are exceptions
uh we expect the sex ratio at the
average age of first reproduction
to be one to one in populations
and you know his logic is a sort of
population level logic
which says basically if you have an
abundance of one sex
parents who can influence the sex ratio
of their own offspring
will end up having better luck in
producing grand offspring
if they produce the sex that is
currently underrepresented in the
population
so i would point out that there's a very
interesting
outgrowth of this discussion i wrote an
essay many years ago
on the hazard of the one child policy in
china that it was going to make china
warlike and that maybe that was even its
purpose because
it produced surplus males who were going
to not be successful in finding mates
and who would constitute the substance
from which an army would naturally be
constructed
and it violates the one child policy
violates the logic of fisher which is to
say
you would expect in a country with a
surplus of males that females would be
prized as offspring which is the
opposite of what we see well it's just
it's not the one child policy itself
does not
either predict this nor violate uh what
fischer found and revealed about sex
ratios it is the
cultural valuing of boy children over
girl children overlaid on a one-child
policy that then produces too many boys
such that you have um not enough not
enough girls and therefore and they're
after not enough women
right so the question in this case
is first of all uh is there conflict
between the population level analysis
and the individual level analysis
in the aftermath of war and which one
should dominate because after all
at least our argument is that it is
lineages that fight wars
typically and that that means that they
are serving a lineage level purpose
well i don't know that there is a
conflict though you know i mean i guess
it it depends on the war
right it depends on the context you know
if if an area has been so devastated
that uh most of the men have been killed
and uh
and the women have been either enslaved
and removed or
raped and inseminated um you don't
necessarily well if they've been
enslaved and removed then you don't
necessarily have a sex ratio
difference right but if uh
if if the women are still there and even
if they now
have within them the children of the of
their
their captors their warlords um
you have uh a a
a likely move both at the individual
level and the population level
to produce more males yes potentially
there's also another possibility here
which is that you would see polygyny
break out in the aftermath of wars which
actually i've predicted would be likely
because it doesn't make sense to
sideline um
women reproductively just because there
aren't you know an equal number of men
so in other words one man can fertilize
many women in the absence of men as a
result of war
you might imagine um that all women
who were capable of producing offspring
would end up with offspring
which i have argued is a basis for um
lesbian coupling that lesbian coupling a
lesbian couple is perfectly capable of
raising offspring
and gametes aren't that hard to get so
not if you're a woman
not if you're a woman um so in any case
there's a deep
question here but the the one the piece
i want to point out
is that warfare is frequently going to
happen at least by our model
when um there when there is
a deficit of resources in other words
austerity causes populations to go to
war
so in one sense if you were going to do
this analysis
and it may be that the analysis has been
done that maybe that peter turton knows
the answer to this question for one
thing
but yeah we don't we don't know we're
talking from an ev
we're trying to make the evolutionary
predictions but we don't actually know
the answer
right yeah but it may be that the answer
is different depending upon whether you
won or lost
right i would imagine that that actually
has some important implications
100 and i i guess i was speaking from
the assumption that we're talking about
the losers
right but the other thing is if
austerity
is generating this and we have made
arguments in other places
for mechanisms to prevent austerity from
causing conflict from causing violence
but in the case that such mechanisms
don't exist or haven't
worked and you have violence in some
sense what it may be doing is backing
the population away from carrying
capacity
which if you do the individual level
analysis
you would expect to have very little
implication because an individual
just because the population may be
better off backing away from
carrying capacity the individual still
has an evolutionary interest in
creating as many copies as they can in
the next generation on the other hand
if we start thinking in lineage level
terms which i would argue we always
should
that at a lineage level it's a very
different analysis because the long-term
well-being of a lineage may
indeed allow for some kind of
restraint with respect to immediate
moving
the immediate move back to carrying
capacity well but it's also true that we
have argued i'm not sure that we have
argued publicly yet but you know it's in
it's in our book that uh that monogamy
actually is a way of filling a landscape
more quickly and so um yes you of course
if you're if you're below carrying
capacity you expect birth rate to go up
sort of an obvious prediction
but you also expect a move further away
from polygeny towards monogamy
as there are more resources available
and more landscape to move into
so i'm alluding to that what i'm getting
at
is that if you have an oscillation at
the at carrying capacity and
warfare results from some boost in
population above
normal carrying capacity that then
results in violence and the violence
is a bloodletting that removes some
people from the population
the evolutionary drive
to go into a population increase mode
that would be facilitated by monogamy
which brings all potential parents into
child rearing that that might not be
incentivized
right so anyway let's just say this is a
complex question
sure um it may be that the pattern you
hypothesize
is there in a general sense it may be
that it's there for
uh winners and not losers or vice versa
um
or it may be that it's absent for other
reasons that
dominate the question and we don't know
but it's certainly worth looking into
you